هؤلاء الرجال يحاولون وفي
الحقيقة وزير الخارجية
يحاول محاربة إيران في أراضينا فلماذا
لا يذهبون إلى إيران لماذا
تلعب الولايات المتحدة هذا الدور في محاربة
إيران من خلال السعوديين في اليمن نحتاج
اليمن مثل اليمن.  نحن بحاجة الينا
جهود جيدة لإحلال السلام في إيمان وعدم
تشجيع السعوديين على بذل المزيد والمزيد من
أجل هذه الحرب بالوكالة التي تقاتل إيران في
اليمن ، فهم ينظرون إليك على أنك
حزب الله الإيراني مثل الوكلاء في اليمن مع
كونك تهديدًا مباشرًا
لحلفائها المملكة العربية السعودية.  هل
تقول إنني أنكر أنه يمكنني القول إذا كانت إيران
تفعل شيئًا يجب على الأمريكيين أن
يعرفوا ما قدمه نيكي هالي في
مجلس الأمن فيما يتعلق
بتدخل ريان في اليمن صواريخ بالاس تيك
يمكنني أن أقول لك مسيحي
هذه الصواريخ لدينا  منذ زمن
بعيد من الروس نقوم بتحسينها
للدفاع عن أنفسنا والإيرانيون لم
يجلبوا أي صواريخ لليمن وأقول
للعالم كله
لدينا صواريخ يمكنها محاربة
السعوديين لسنوات.